[Music]
alright so we just got done watching
first man yes on IMAX it's pretty good I
think it's a Ryan Gosling guy from yeah
course is about space program
it was reminded me a lot of 2001 yeah it
would you think of it I actually thought
it was amazing I really really liked
what I liked to the parries detail in
like we said it was curriculum but it's
not it's not real cold
my kids are it's almost I don't like a
handheld camera but a lot of it it
almost kind of looks like yeah mattified
it has kind of it looks like it was shot
on on 60s film stuff yeah it does so it
takes you back to they really kind of
puts you in I mean these Ryan Gosling
please Neil Armstrong and they really
almost kind of like put you in his shoes
they're so like when he's in the capsule
like when they're going to launch is
like that you feel like you're in the
capsule and like how it looked in life
yeah and the sound effects you were like
that's really loud bubbling like you
know just like said they're like
seriously the opening sequence like
where they're doing because it kind of
covers like you know like a 89 year
period of time like the beginning of you
know where they were trying to do all
the time
your program and stuff like that so
there's like all these different things
that happen along the way like before
the innovating
and like the opening sequence of him
like doing that test and stuff like that
I was stressing it's like feeling like
it really did feel like you Roseanne's
where I was sitting there going I think
I I so you liked it I felt like I
thought it was really really good
I liked it mostly that was a Miss mixed
bag though I I think you know I don't
know how historically accurate love that
was how accurate they were portraying
the Armstrongs character and the
relationship with his wife I had a
feeling that it was kind of contrived
that was kind of bothering me a little
bit like I said I'm not really sure like
I was under the impression that an
astronaut's wives were basically
astronauts that Terr mentality that they
knew everything that was going on in
there pretty tough and some of the stuff
that in the when you when you see the
movie the way it's written towards the
end it starts to for me I interpreted as
pessimism that that them that the movie
said Armstrong shouldn't have gone to
the moon because I'm a man that's how I
interpret it because the way he was
dealing with the wife and the wife is
blaming him for going yeah but no but
the whole point of that last scene and
that and all that you should the whole
point of the last scene where they did
the thing on the glass that was them
reconnect emulation
yeah I bet you there wasn't any I bet
you there wasn't any any any problem
between those two she probably wanted
him to go to another thing I didn't like
about it though is that they were
building it up going to the moon they
get to the moon they don't spend much
time on the moon they don't show the
stuff that they did on the moon didn't
show the lunar rover so you I'm waiting
this whole times that man's gonna be
badass when they get to the moon
they don't really [ __ ] show you just
get em on and they go yeah watching porn
and they don't really do the [ __ ]
money shot and like I said I'm not sure
I haven't read like a biography of Neil
Armstrong so I don't know I kept like it
sure it's pretty fairly accurate because
it seems like all the other stuff like
all the period detail all that [ __ ]
about NASA and stuff like that was like
they could see like they tried to get
that like as accurate as possible I
would even if that was acted as possible
I said if I would have make it if I was
making this movie I would alive I would
have made that [ __ ] I would have made
that [ __ ] optimistic and [ __ ] badass
as possible like [ __ ] it no we're gonna
moon out and then I'd have planted the
flag dropping your nuts dropping the
nuts on the [ __ ] Soviet Union that's
right [ __ ] and I would have done that
way you know mythology sometimes it's
better than in real life it's just it's
weird course you're supposed to go to
the moon it's never let a woman hold you
back and go on the moon no it's
that's how I interviewed now I just
might just stop I'm glad I talked about
just our own level that's I don't think
that's all right do you think the movies
were watchable yeah like I said I really
liked it it was almost like if you give
it Stanley Kubrick a handycam yeah and
had him make a movie like back then like
when he was still making movies and as I
was watching it though I was wondering I
was like this is awesome in the theater
I was thinking this probably would
translate too well to television
you'd have even had to have a badass
ounces yeah because a lot of a lot of
what is good about the visuals yeah and
like I said seeing in IMAX I really felt
like I'm with these astronauts yes
rickety-ass rockets go first to third
movie balls the first two-thirds of the
movie I thought it was kicking ass
within that there's something about that
last 1/3 of the movie I thought it's
starting to sell out on me I was like
going man you know we made it to the
moon and you're not really gonna [ __ ]
show us the moon you know not in any
detail I just I was I was kind of let
down kind of disappointed with it but
you know some people might like the
movie the whole movie was about the
lead-up and and the acting of the acting
was so good and the script was pretty
even though I can't even though I kind
of thought the relationships were
contrived I still like the movie uh you
know there's still like the script I
just didn't like the moon sequence when
they got through the month they that you
show us the [ __ ] moment we're not
alone long enough and then I thought and
I interpret it the way it was being way
it was written in the way it was being
shown to me I interpreted as pessimism
that they should have gone to the moon
that's the way it that's the way
Enterprise because why it's it made it
seemed to me that his wife do I approve
the SEC his wife didn't approve it him
going to the moon well she it wasn't so
much heard that was bothered she was
just saying she was she didn't like tell
him not to go
she just said she just looked at him no
she was looking at him with his eyes
away one looks at you like no she just
said alright so you give it thumbs up
I'm saying now don't worry about it
I'm have this agree I'm going to say it
was a well made movie but it missed the
mark they wasted a bunch of time turn it
was good yeah they're going to they get
to the mode and then [ __ ] the moon we're
not going to show you the moon or to
spend like two minutes on the moon man I
waited the whole time if I could go to
the moon then I think it's super moon
there's nothing it's just let's get out
of here
you
all right so yeah we're at AMC actually
missed doing the intro I did the intro
[ __ ] it up on the way in well I think
it's another fungus we don't really need
introduced we [ __ ] up the last one
yeah we saw bad times at the El Royale
went in what was it was the 1:30 show
yeah walked in this private 15-20 people
most of them older people I don't know
just retirees I guess that's the way it
is
so El Royale started off basically kind
of seemed kind of like Quentin Tarantino
film the war type movie reminded me a
lot of Pulp Fiction without Quentin
Tarantino's annoying dialog but other
than that I mean it had a tight script
and now it didn't I don't know I guess
it was all right what do you think of it
um I really liked it honestly it's kind
of like the oh and the only sense that
it was like Quentin Tarantino was like
it was kind of structured instructions
like it yeah it was pretty linear but it
would kind of like go back in time and
show you things bunch of different
characters each one of them with their
own backgrounds yes like the whole theme
of the movie was like no one being what
they appeared on the surface like you
know you would see and you would think
this particular thing about this
character then they would go and tell
their pastor or it actually reminded me
a little not so much Quentin Tarantino
minds me of a color Brothers movie if
you like come on Brothers movies
appreciate it remind me of No Country
for Old Men a little bit same type of
thing and you know was kind of like an
agent of chaos that comes like lead in
the movie
sort of same kind of thing is
so it kind of reminded me of like a Coen
Brothers movie visually it looked really
good I really like yeah it was set like
in the late sixties early sixties and
seventies gemenon was going on and it
was just kind of all set around this
hotel you know as like I said all these
characters kind of showed up and they
all have like some yeah the hotel has a
secret right you can't really can't
spoil it or anything like that so it's
like all this kind of like intrigue
happens and you learn all these kind of
things I particularly really liked Jon
Hamm in this electrolux yeah so I liked
him a lot
the what's his name he was from altered
state bridges yes yeah yeah he was
really good it's like the acting
ensemble was really good and like I said
it kind of like really kept yours like
with this person's story it's over
that's it and then like you'd see it
from different perspectives and stuff so
I really kind of like that it's like it
kind of sucked cuz people - like would
not shut up yeah low IQ that yellow IQ
people and it's like well I think they
even turned their phone on at one point
because I've heard another guy in the
back don't stop the turn there yeah and
I was like I was gonna turn around and
go but yeah so it didn't like we're in
the movie or anything but I I just heard
them chattering back he's preaching - I
think yeah he's preaching yeah yeah I
didn't hear what they were saying I just
heard like over like I just heard the
noise about Jesus well well what a
characters pretending to be a Pete
priest and whenever he would say
something about Jesus you know there you
go Friday there's a fake priest yeah but
yeah I mean overall like I said if you
dig Coen Brothers movies you would
probably really like this because it's
similar type of similar type of movie
you know it's
I don't know I liked it a lot and like
you said visually it was really cool
it's like a like a long period detail
the hotel itself like the really really
nice design of it's kind of like it's
kind of like a down-and-out hotel but
like a few years ago it was like super
famous and it was like there was casinos
and stuff and so it had still kind of
kind of a nice look but it was like
empty cuz no one sit there anymore but
yeah she'd give it thumbs up yeah
alright I didn't like it I didn't like
he doesn't like it I don't like this
kind of movies it was I don't like that
kind of structured storytelling the way
that is to me I think that was kind of
played out in the Tarantino era when
that came out oh yeah that's cool but
yeah I look at it now and I see it as a
throwback and I started to kind of lose
my patience with it it was very slow for
me yeah very slow and I didn't really
find most of the characters interesting
and the ones that were the one the
vacuum cleaner guy I thought he was
interesting and they kill him off pretty
pretty early there's not to me there
just wasn't much to the movie but it
like I said I think it says genre you're
looking at kind of crazy like a neo noir
type of thing yeah if you're into that
you'd probably like it's not like I said
I don't it didn't really make me think
of a Tarantino because I like some
Tarantino movies but his movies are very
affected yeah yeah it's just like
everything has to be hip lingo so it
didn't really had that it was a lot more
that's what I said yeah didn't he didn't
have his terrible dialogue yeah it was
dialogues good but it's just so it's so
self-conscious I like that like you know
people wouldn't really talk
and this side like a lot more this was a
lot more normal like normal people
talking but yeah so you know if it's
your thing
yeah this is your kind of movie then you
know alright
all right way back at AMC 15 we're gonna
see Christopher Robin where is that [ __ ]
there it is and this kind of date as
always here at this hour
they keep asking to see my ID on the way
in and that [ __ ] sees me everybody's
dead
damn feels like it's a feels like it's a
full-time job watching these movies and
most of them [ __ ] suck to see I don't
look at that nobody's here look at that
we're the only one here playing a long
time and nobody gives a [ __ ]
this [ __ ] up nearly the battle nobody
here since your fine ass down I don't
know anything so back to work all this
graphic design ya know and then we got
to go out and see these movies three
times a week I'm tempted to just
schedule them so we'll just see three of
them in one day get it over with
yeah
not my bigger thing it's just because I
had too much unexpected work
[Music]
yeah audio book falling behind and it's
already recorded just got to do all the
editing she thought we thought they were
did she'd be ready this week but they
just miss graphic design work [ __ ]
around with star nitros [ __ ] around
the star tonight me playing with their
phone I'm going to tell that story on
the show look at back on it yeah it
looks like you're funny yeah it was a
bad vibe in the theatre that day see
people would look seemed like people
were [ __ ] going around in the bed and
then behind us we've had creatures
behind us the whole time preaching amen
how do you get everything a great
picture was saying and [ __ ] me over
like you idiot that is a fake [ __ ]
priest
I think who is I think is no [ __ ] 65
IQ shine in Peru
amen hallelujah yeah
we're gonna call it quest for now we get
back
[ __ ] I'm cover us a microphone
alright so we just got back seeing
Christopher Robin I'm gonna you tell him
about it it was ok what's up here you
have a period piece yeah no no no it was
before right after World War one
oh man 1920s okay yeah it's not 20s and
30s right yeah now post-war but yeah it
was like honestly it was like way better
than I was expecting
yeah it was delightful and honestly the
um I don't know I'm guessing they did
like a combination of puppetry and CGI
I think I saw CGI it did look like but
it really did not look like CGI yeah I
didn't know but I think it was it
probably was but if it was it was the
most amazing CGI I've ever seen because
it really didn't look like a walking
talking walking talking stuff down story
was pretty good I guess it was a little
meandering to me sometimes sometimes I
was kind of looted sometimes I was
losing track of it but it was a pleasant
story yeah I would say it's for an adult
audience I think yeah there's a lot of
adult leaves in it oh the bad things
kind of like the pitfalls are growing up
really that's it's not really a pure
kids movie because it's not like it's
like I said it's a period piece it's
based very much more on the books by AML
so there was like a lot of you know
chords and stuff
and yeah it just basically had his
concern like Christopher Robin like
after he grew up and then he kind of
become this sort of stick-in-the-mud
yeah we went to World War one and when
he comes back out of World War one and
he ends up working for a company and you
kind of yeah
kind of kind of lose it's a boring old
exactly so and then what happens is the
his old animal childhood friends coming
basically save you
yeah like actually like Pooh Bear has to
come into his world because all his
friends are lost and stuff so that and
then they have to kind of go back and
save each other
yeah but like I said it's like the
little characters in this this is funny
but like and those of you that watch our
show like normally because I call her
kitty baby cookie I call her blue bear
sometimes Jackson why because like the
Pooh Bear character in this and I know
that like the guy that used to do the
voice for Winnie the Pooh I think is a
massive bashing Cabot I'm pretty sure
you passed away many years ago but um
the person that does the moist of
waiting to through this time comes use
pretty much exactly like him like a
really totally different actually all
the words are sounded pretty much just
like they did in the cartoon like any
other stuff so um I really said that was
kind of cool and but the way the way
Pooh Bear was like the way he's like
acting and he's like messing everything
up and he's all like no way to walk that
he's off that yeah yeah what's why is it
one of the things I kind of liked about
it is that the look of the creatures is
that they look like like worn out
stuffed animals yeah they're kind of you
can think I wear on them and they've
kind of faded yeah like Tigger isn't
really our and she's kind of he's almost
kind of whited out a little bit yeah
they were all kind of like feet in there
Brogan you looking like an like piglets
face like you can see like the little
fabric yeah the way on the cheeks and
stuff like that and they looked like
that back when Christopher Robin was a
little kid too so they think they always
what I remember
but I would think out of all of this
week's movies that probably enjoyed this
one the most yeah which is weird because
I wasn't sure like I said I love you in
regard to winning food stories I always
really liked you know the cartoon
version that does need it many years ago
so I thought that I would enjoy this but
it was actually it was it was kind of
different than when I was expecting so
it was actually much better than I was
expecting it was like you said it was a
lot more adult yeah even though even
though at the end I don't know if the
little economic model actually worked he
just turned a triangle upside down and
he said well we'll let everybody go on
vacation and that will save the company
I don't really think that works out well
no because he was saying that if more
people could afford to go on vacation
that more people would buy their luggage
but that was they could only let the
people in the company go on vacation
though that was a weird thing that I
wasn't of the story was that Christopher
Robin like I said it lost his way
forever is important he was like all he
did was work all the time he was like
neglecting who's yeah
wife and daughter and so you know him
going back to the Hundred Acre Wood and
like reconnecting with all the little
animal friends you know we were just
kind of like you know they're like
little children one of those you know
kind of getting ahead of ourselves one
of the side plots was as Christopher
Robin had to help save the company he
worked for yeah because he was kind of
like an he was telling Human Resources
slash efficiency type guy and he didn't
want to fire everybody you know the
company was going undergoing a lot of
problems they were trying to do things
like reduced costs and he was stressing
out about he had a bunch of paper we've
been working on for a long time but the
the way they resolved the problem was to
let everyone go on vacation and that
that's all yeah that wasn't pay for that
that wouldn't pay for the [ __ ] that
way to save the company though I don't
know how they got that in there that
wouldn't save the company no I know but
it's like it's just
oh well you know being a man I expect
their actual I wanted to see him really
solve the problem though okay then I
like they didn't he didn't really solve
the problem but only but yeah it was it
was much better than really my favorite
part of it was the animations like I
really loved the character we were in
there there was actually only one other
person in the theatre yeah but yeah I
actually realized it yeah a decent movie
yes I liked it better than first man
yeah I think
[Music]